you did drunk history what how did
kessler find out
let's talk about drunk history because
you guys were in pre-production for
season seven
and then they stabbed us all in the
heart and told us that it would not be
coming back so
what happened like how did you get the
news how did you react how are you
feeling
it's hard you know i i'll never be the
like oh poor me i don't have a tv show
anymore
i'm so thankful for having it but
yeah it was shooting it being able to
like
be cut off you know i don't mind it
being over but i would love to finish
what i started
so i still don't really understand why
they did it or why
you know i could have made something
like what i made for this and kind of
like i thought i could just do
it like the original web series like end
the show like
the youtube series and just do it in the
backyard with really dumb wigs and
funny outfits but i'm thankful for the
time i had there but
i am it's unfortunate it bums me
like how do we save drunk history like
what do you need me to do it's such an
impactful show
it means so much do you like do you have
conversations happen about it maybe
finding a new home do you have hope that
it might
i hope i i have hope that it might
yeah i just have to i got to get it back
i humbly say that like there's
there's no way i wouldn't like figure
out a way to come back in a couple years
and make like a special or you know
stuff like that i just i think it was a
bad decision
and that we were doing really uh
interesting stories that
were before the time where everyone's
like hey we should be including everyone
yeah
we should be including everybody it
would be nice to come back like every
once in a while and
do like a special i think that would
happen you guys always
just got that right and told all of
these very underrepresented stories and
all these facets of history that were
kind of unknown and i feel like the show
is so special that it
it must go on thank you yeah the goal of
that show is always
the best story should be told by the
best people and so that's just
the way a good story is told i'm bummed
but i'm also proud of what we left
behind
and uh would love to finish it and
and do more down the road but i'm also
excited to do new stuff
and not to deal with drunk people
anymore it's going to be nice
that's the one the good part i'm pretty
drunk
you feel okay i'm giggly and there's
gaps
in my memory i'm sorry already so did
you guys shoot
anything for the new season like are
there episodes that
oh man okay so yeah so all the store we
do all
we do research first and then we do the
narration part
and so all of the narrators are finished
and so we were just about to do all the
fun
lip syncing reenactment the way i was
gonna end it
which was very exciting for me is uh
called teacher appreciation episode
where it was every narrator
talking about their favorite teacher and
then i talked about mine and then
mr stang my history teacher shows up on
the show and gets drunk and tells the
story of the whiskey rebellion with
alexander hamilton and
that was just the best like i had a
little school desk
and like we had some maryland flags in
the back we
i found my binder that i had in his
class and he like re-graded my papers
and
i don't know everyone wants to like be
friends with their teacher he's just my
hero and i just thought the show
was getting to a place where i was able
to do whatever i wanted and i'm like
let's give credit where it's due and
then you know
teachers you know do unappreciate it you
know so i thought that would be a cool
way to end
but so that with that one i'm mostly
disappointed because i really wanted to
have mr stang on tv but
also nicole byer told this amazing story
about stagecoach mary who's a former
slave
who then becomes the first female postal
worker which
is uh pretty topical now
i think we had like 35 stories ready
wow okay yeah those can't just go in a
vault they have to go you would hope not
you would hope
not but yeah you take the good with the
bad the positives outweigh the negatives
right ashley
yeah sorry i didn't mean to bring you
down oh no no no no no no
i'm no i'm i'm up i'm on the quest to
save drunk history that's all i love
your quest
i think that's a great quest on the
positive note you guys
are nominated yet again for the emmys
which are right around the corner
for i believe three nominations included
right yep customs
customs and production design and the
show yeah
how are you feeling about uh the emmys
being virtual oh man ashley
uh this is definitely not um a humble
brag
or like uh it's definitely like a funny
problem to have it's not really a
problem but
everyone has to record their speech as
if they won did you know that
no yeah so i put on a tuxedo i didn't
wear a um
tie but i did a tuxedo and shirt and um
yeah you have to like 30 seconds act
like you won i'm like how do i
not know this needs to be destroyed if
we don't win
like for that to exist yes
i just thought about that chris klein
audition that leaked i was just like i
just felt so bad for him like i don't
i don't somebody's watching these going
like look at these guys they think
they're gonna win
that i like about it is that day is the
scariest
craziest day of i haven't feel like you
have to go to the bathroom 20
every 20 minutes and so i think the
anxiety will be
lower knowing like oh if we win
i don't have to say anything now because
yeah cause you already did
i already did and uh they asked if you
had like if you'd wanted to like
hold up emmy and i grabbed my 910
ltrc uh trophy from baseball and helped
that so
i'm hoping it brings me a good luck well
what would it mean to you to win
i know people are like ah i'm just happy
to be nominated but come on
i think there's a different when like
with the show getting cancelled
it would really be a really good it
would be a louder huzzah
than normally obviously being able to a
make a tv show and be
for it to be recognized like this is
just
is so cool but but to win yeah i'm not
gonna lie that would be
like it would help ending the show on
that note you know
right or be like by the way
you want to pick this show up we got
we'll get you an emmy
yeah exactly yeah yeah do you want to
buy an emmy uh
winning show
you are working with represent us to
which helps ensure all americans have
options to vote safely and securely in
the 2020 election
and you've been pretty active in
election education i think drug history
did it really well why is this such an
important thing to you
it's very important to me um for many
reasons and one that you know democracy
and fighting for what's right not like
what's good or bad is what's right
you know and i was very honored that
they reached out to me because
we're all in this situation
and there's so many things where you
feel inadequate and
uh anything that i can do to help get
what's right
done i i just i i want to help but yeah
we've done
a lot of election stuff on the show and
so this just felt like oh
this would be a perfect time to learn
about the absentee ballot
there's going to be music and sketches
and just kind of
helping teach you know what the
importance of voting by mail and how we
can do it safely
and uh just getting the awareness of
that there's many people that aren't
able to go into us
even if it's a safe place whether it be
a disability or trying to
work right now that we're all in this
almost emergency room
and we need to help everyone so we get
the job done
we're doing it right and so the show is
focusing on kind of
humanizing and realizing you know what
this means what the absentee ballot
means what you know
voting by mail is and why we need to be
safe and smart about it
so one of the the big drills i think for
me as a drunk history fan
is that you guys are airing what could
be
the final episode of drunk history you
guys are live streaming it during this
event
yeah could this be final it is not a
traditional drunk history it's
specifically a drunk social distancing
history of where the absentee ballot
started from and it was the good old
honest day but always comes from the
good old honest ape
a lot of soldiers weren't really going
to vote for him at that time when they
thought he was a little too radical what
he did in atlanta and i don't want to
give it away
but it's a drunk uh social distancing
history
of where the absentee ballon i did it
with the great john kason who's an
editor for ours and i i was just like oh
it'd be really funny to just
take the images of people and then put
his eyes and mouth
inside of it and we don't have to like
cause any kind of uh
unsocial distancing thing so it was
really fun and i
hope you like
[Music]